il ya 37 squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans une tenue absolument
ridicule pour sa vie ses cuisses de
grenouilles situe à entretenir vraiment
aujourd'hui sur just dance et je propose
qu'on danse aviation va accuser des
fajitas alors qu'on est sur just dance 2
serait dommage on va commencer avec une
chanson que je la trouvais bollywood
santa x mas tulle et ça tombe bien
puisque c'est bientôt noël c'est parti
il existe un nouveau concours je m'en
bats les steaks
oui le bouton je m'en bats les steaks
vous êtes le bas est ce qu'on est prêt
vous dansez aussi avec moi al je saurai
si vous dans ses pattes manière je le
saurai pas de recours mais ouais je suis
le foot ça va être super rapide à du
bollywood eu mon gars ok on était de
ceinture invisible j'aime bien sceptique
à sion ok j'étais en fait qu'est-ce que
tu vas nous demander beaucoup
vestimentaire ils m'ont interpellé me
laissent pas le temps aux [ __ ] ok on
est prêt à vous pour affirmer une jolie
femme avec moisissent commerce à ce bon
père noël bien pervers et sa longue
barbe
moi j'ai pas le droit une fille met
d'accord j'ai compris au maire mêmes
idéaux les gars j'ai pas mis les on
connaît la terreur du nombre des eaux en
jouant deux dabistes
je respecte sa disparition ou les biens
meubles et prend ses marques y en a mais
je dois plutôt flatteur à blâmer les
gammes
mais comment mourir d'un infarctus le
moins de deux minutes quand s'il vous
plaît je me dis qu'ils ambitionnent de
pièces plastiques
qu'est ce qui a changé à sa demande
moins d'efforts de joie far cry ya des
années où en plus de marques la galère
mais je ne peux pas monter sur les
éléphants n'ont lieu d'être quand même
dansé avec leurs tombes c'est pas
possible
et je parle pas du danser avec la tombe
lequel vous pensez - de père mère non
mais stop demandé juste à des mots
j'attends donc j'ai tenté j'ai pas
réussi j'ai l'impression que là je me
suis défoncé le chili oh mais du coup sa
part au repas date pourtant de la fuite
dans ce manga mais arrêtez de sauter
[ __ ] déjà vous vous n'avez pas de
voisins mot journée un trois étoiles
nouvel avatar débloquer testé deux
passes 7 1987 ses engagements approche
mais un
c'est intimidant pas non avoir regardé
et regarder comment droit de manière nul
danser ça suffit non je ne veux pas
partager ça à ça ça me plaît ça fait ça
va être bien doubiens tranquille de
belles silhouettes de fans pas du tout
courbet merci à tous merci ça me rend
extrêmement plaisir
j'ai peur de la suite est-ce que vous
êtes prêts c'est parti oh [ __ ] j'adore
à l étranger au but allez je peux enfin
de montrer ce des objets légendaires aux
jeunes j'ai un point de côté j'aime
moins aller du 6 mars plein art l appel
à m donc c'était me fait toujours
semblant de marché ne pas caler sur type
entourage
ah ça fait du bien après bollywood
franchement c'est bizarre mais ça fait
vraiment du bien on en mes moyens
la fille est là ça part comme ça ok ok
non non oui mouture de ces corps hockey
au [ __ ] à bollywood
ça va ça va c'est léger
non mais les gars à l'égal égales eh
bien il ya dans ce cadre je suis sûre du
parquet tu rembourser les factures ya
aucun problème
avatar mais ses propos se gardant pas
possible c'est de la triche
moi je veux monde à ma cinquième étoile
[Musique]
non mais on est bon on est beaux meubles
importés en bourse a pu mettre d'autres
profils que j'ai eue de tous les jeux
auxquels j'ai pu jouer dans ma vie c'est
parce que c'est moi où je joue contre
mon pied je comprends profiler plus tard
ses deux jambes bandées un [ __ ] de
ficelle ou mikado enfin un truc fois un
loup est moche je vais mourir à celle
elle va pas passer ça va c'est mignon oh
oui c'est tout doux
mais si j'ai un truc qui commence un peu
doucement comme ça qui finit extrêmement
rapide et chiant quand la berceuse
j'vous jure
ah oui aucun problème je le colle mes
genoux si tu veux ça te fait plaisir
avec un pool avrillé alexandra 600 basse
j'aime beaucoup vraiment ça sans savoir
à quel moment ça va partir c'est ça il
faut se demande tout à l'heure actuelle
on est calme on est calme on est calme
on est vraiment j'étais à cette fois on
était calmes ça s'accélère s'accélère on
se calme ou scan mikami aux mamans
savent cela s'accélère
j'accélère s'il vous plaît elle acheta
gatwech à chaque jeu le jeu en rendent à
chaque jour à l'estec au [ __ ] au
pétage de samba et et y est je le tape
pas quand même un peu je veux dire
carrément moi je trouve vraiment souza
dit nous est très vivant j'aime beaucoup
cette tour et j'ai fait tous les jours
en boîte je voulais montrer qu'une fille
à la maison quand vous le prendre mon
[ __ ] ses orgies au podium ça pendant
ses luges et partenaires aux deux
papables fils de chien n'est pas mal on
n'est pas mal
je suis perdu je suis complètement
bienvenus allez fais ça calmement c'est
chopin politis exercent
ça ne pouvait pas tout il a beaucoup
moins ça elle peut faire un plus haut à
la semaine photo de profil mieux que
celle d'abord bien dénoncer cette
détresse dans le regarde tes tristes et
amis c'est pour nous et pour lui un mois
je vais compte des gens des états unis
et d'allemagne
non mais ça c'est de la liane la triche
la cub on va dire je suis bleu la whey
danse aussi comme un bon gros loser
mais hormis les gamins mais les gars ça
mais on va sans boiter pendant tout le
truc c'est ça hein et sans boiter comme
je pense
elles sont galère vous fait n'importe
quoi ce que génial pour avec une
calandre une tambouille à trois mecs
devant leur télé qui sont dans le même
état que nos équipes ont pas une vidéo
qui pensent avoir regardé et je touche
la boule g pour la prison l'a pris à moi
je me mets du milieu comme ça ça mais en
beaucoup moins d'efforts juste mais là
il ya un problème il ya un problème
gbagbo s'il encaisse accès la rocqué
d'accord j'ai compris j'ai compris ya un
problème
qu'est-ce qui se passe
ok fait que tu croyais plus tard allez
on y retourne n'y retournera pas tant on
fait comme ça du mouvement pourquoi
c'est toujours moi qui fais un truc là
mais regardez c'est moi il ya puisque sa
faiblesse ce camp à l'autre au plus tard
le bateau otage une claquette
et alors quoi voilà du bon mais je suis
bon ok crazy mais vous savez ce que
c'est c'est ça pardon propose à tous
battus donald qui vient me dire joli
style
merci mid muteront choisir un pseudo
plus facile j'aime moi on est premier
mais deux ou trois diamants taillés
mange pas là pour fêter avec quoi les
moments importants de la vie comme ça je
n'aime pas l'école one la ligne à manger
walden linda roy manger bon ben voila
j'ai déjà fin de cette vidéo sur just
dance 2015 on peut être fier de nous on
a battu quatre joueurs du monde entier
trois étaient 3,4 avec jumbo même si je
jouais pas je perds c'est là le plus
c'est qu'elle n'hésitait pas aimé la
vidéo comme d'habitude je vous invite à
m'affronter sur just dance
même si je jouerai pas avant trois mois
et demi vu comment j'ai frôlé
l'infarctus plusieurs fois marc savard
regarder ensemble on travaille dans une
nouvelle vidéo chat au monde
pis
[Applaudissements]